on a un client important qui nous a fait
confiance pour qu'on lui organise un
mariage crée en main alors on va lui
montrer qu'il a eu raison de nous
choisir j'aimerais bien qu'on évite les
tensions ses toiles est autant un garçon
calme
non non je veux personne dans champs
rien une vieille dans le champ elle
avait sa ma mère je vous ai dit que je
voulais un truc sobre chic et rigueur
oui mais c'est complètement l'esprit
donc je compte sur vous pour que ce soit
particulièrement en face une belle
soirée ce qu'ils ont à me prendre le
bateau là projet de cuisine votre
comportement votre politesse c'est la
vitrine de la réception elle de vous
préciser que je ne suis pas un grand
orateur est la championne alors stoppé
son ami tu es sûr de toi là pour les
feux d'artifice
qu'est ce que je vous ai dit j'ai dit on
se coordonne
[Musique]
est ce que mon fils vous a transmis ma
liste de chansons alors non je m'en
doutais je vous ai apporté un
enregistrement legroux soirée punk que
en perspective
[Musique]